so let's do it let's do it man let's uh
you know we're doing it every week my
bets your money
i'm going to go some go through some
games in the national football league
and i'm not saying i will put money on
this mike smith
yep but if you gave me some money i
would
all right let's go uh i want to go
giants cowboys on this
giants cowboys you know what's so funny
on this game i see east oof
okay yeah okay cool all right look
dallas the reason this game gets my
attention for a couple of reasons
one um if mike mccarthy does not win
this game
he may be fired before leaving the
stadium
this is a it's not a must-win game for
the cowboys because their division is so
terrible
it's a must-win game for mike mccarthy
i think already if they don't make the
playoffs i think he's going to be one
and done
it's a little unfair because it's a
pandemic
but if you don't beat one of the worst
football teams that i've seen in the
last
well i'd say 15 or 20 years the giant
seriously
you don't beat them mike mccarthy might
be out and by the way
i still don't know why the coach don't
forget to make the storyline
don't forget the major storyline to add
to the to the pressure
what's the major story there jason
garrett oh
goodness and you know and listen you
forgot what he did
you forgot what he ended up as most of
us did no no i didn't i didn't remember
until this week
i looked it up so i looked it up a
couple weeks ago
and said you know where did jason
garrett go and then to the giants
i said so what it doesn't even matter
because he's not doing anything he's
gonna get nobody's
if jason gets offense if jason garrett's
offense
cooks that dallas defense no i'm just
backing you up on your point about mike
mccarthy
i am just i agree with you 100 whether
whether mike mccarthy or mike nolan or
whoever's
somebody getting fired somebody getting
fired
if they lose to the giants at the crib
this is why i said
this is why you're taking dallas dallas
will blow them out this is my points bet
right here you see it right there points
bet
dallas will blow them out
this is a probably a three touchdown
uh dallas victory so okay so roll with
that one roll with that one
now chiefs raiders i think this is an
opportunity mike
you know it's an old school rivalry uh
rivalry game chiefs raiders
you're a student of nfl history as i am
so
i have to have the music playing in my
head right now yeah oh this is some
nastiness buchanan absolutely oh yeah
yeah yeah this is great this is great
old memorial
stadium in kansas city you know coach
david is a raider
there it is there it is all right
i'm gonna make some money for you i'm
going with vegas on this one
i'm going with vegas at 11.
kansas city is an excellent team kenton
city is a championship team
um but in this rivalry game
all sorts of crazy things happen
i think kansas city wins the game i
think they win it by 10.
uh you're gonna be in good shape put a
lot of money i'm gonna put a lot of your
money
on the las vegas raiders how you feel
about it mike
i like it you're not feeling i like it
yeah i like it no i know i like it i
like i mean because
the raiders um the renegade
raiders of course the raiders would be
the historically the most penalized team
in the league of course that'd be the
team that doesn't besides the titans
that
has something against masks uh they're
good team they're a competitive team
they're a good team
they're better uh i think they're better
than
yeah they'll keep it i can see it i can
see a 10. i don't think it's gonna be
close per se but i can see it settling
at 10. i i like i like where your head's
at with that 11 yeah that is the healthy
spray
i'm just you know this is i'm looking
for opportunities just to make a little
extra cash for you
with your money right all right guys all
right all right finally
not love this matchup you've got the
cleveland browns
and you've got the indianapolis colts
they're both three and one right and you
know what
this game is a pick em game right
so uh you can go either way with this
um one thing i like about the cleveland
browns
not just that they're three and one but
they seem
they have found and i'm amazed by this
they found
an identity kevin stefanski
kevin stefanski i need to apologize to
you again
i didn't i didn't i didn't think they'd
be able to do this
and i thought all the transitional
coaches like i told you before all these
coaches
taking over programs i think was go i
thought it was going to be very
difficult
to win immediately because you you've
got as you pointed out so beautifully at
the beginning of the show
you've got extraordinary circumstances
this is we've never seen an nfl like
this before doing business like this no
no exhibition games no in not a lot of
in-person meetings
so it's hard to really establish a
culture when you come in but kevin
stefanski and the browns
i think they're legit okay
okay i don't know i i want to give some
some quick browns commentary you know
why they're legit you know what
let's get some let's show some love
let's let's let's get let's show the
brother some love
um you you're familiar with this this
this young man i can call him a young
man he's grown man i come a young man
i'm eight years older than him for
crying out loud
uh 33 year old andrew berry harvard's
own
andrew barrett yep yep general manager
of the browns
who if they keep this up
i know he didn't draft odell beckham uh
i know he didn't
excuse me i know he didn't sign or trade
for odell beckham
um i know he didn't draft baker mayfield
as what i meant to say
um but man they had a hell of an off
season
and a hell of an offseason um when it
comes to
uh drafting uh jindrick willis in the
first round
um they went out and uh
signed austin hooper and free agency
they signed jack conklin and free agency
so they really to that identity kevin
stefanski is able to play into that
identity
uh traded for andy janovich fullback not
a big that's a big headline that's not a
headline grabber
um uh but they really
invested in the strength of that team
which is going to be their running game
you know that's because hey yeah because
look
um nick chubb is down but you got kareem
hunt who
not that long league in rushing um
you know deionis johnson coming in
leading the team in russian last week i
believe it was
so really good off season
from uh from that young general manager
uh listen and they
already had a lot of talent from all
those years of drafting high although
no actually i'll take that back it
didn't have a lot of talent just drafted
high because they blew a lot of those
draft picks
they blew it out yeah they were a
talented team coming in but they just
all they finally had an off-season
that's manifested itself the money the
money was well spent let's put it that
way so
uh you know this is why the future
manager of the year
executive of the year andrew berry go
ahead well you mentioned andrew berry
you mentioned
investment and this is
my bet your money i'm gonna invest i'm
gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna advise that you
invest in this pickum no it's not an
opportunity to make huge amount of money
like the raiders one
but the cleveland browns are gonna win
this game they're gonna win this game
probably by
a touchdown hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports